as we pointed out earlier the cap
dropped 15.7 million exacerbated by the
fact that it usually goes up by at least
10 million a year it has every year
since 2013 that's 25.7 million that has
caused teams to begin the process of
moving on from veteran players now some
of these guys would have been cut anyway
but emmanuel sanders would he had been
cut by the saints after only one year
with the team probably not quan
alexander a guy that arrived late last
year now he had a big cap number for
this year he probably would have still
been in trouble anyway but when you're
trying everything you can to get under
the cap these are the people who stand
out and these are the guys who are going
to be gone and it's going to continue
riley reeve remember last year the
vikings were going to let him go they
reworked the contract and after the
season when they gave him a million
dollar bonus because he fell just short
of a playing time incentive i wish i
would have said it because my thought
was yeah they're they're
they're making good with him now because
they know they're gonna dump him going
into 2021 and he was released yesterday
so this is going to continue into next
week and beyond as teams consistently
scour the roster
who are the guys that we can move on
from and create some cap space save some
cash and replace with someone who dollar
for dollar is a better value than the
guy we have it is a cold heartless
aspect to the business i asked that
question last week to rick spielman the
vikings gm in just very generic fashion
how do you balance this how do you do it
he said that's what we do that's our
obligation and that that's the kind of
callous you have to have on your soul
when it comes to saying this guy's out
this guy's in this guy's out this guy's
in that's the way it goes for nfl teams
yeah that's right i mean at some point
they just have to look at them as
entities and not people you know and
then of course when you make that
decision as the entity you try to switch
it back to okay now let me be a person
and call this guy and tell them how
grateful i was for that time and all
it's a it's a delicate balance for head
coaches and gm's you know it's not easy
it's a special skill set there too you
know hey kevin zeitler you know on that
that and that uh little graphic we had
the guard for the giants i mean he's
still really damn good
i mean he's one of the better guards in
football still i mean i'm not saying top
five but he's
top ten-ish he's really like still a
powerhouse there's a lot of good play
left in him you know that that's like
that to lose to that guy to be on the
street right now i think in a normal
year i'd have a hard time thinking a guy
like that would have been cut to your
point mike i want to ask you this like
there's i have like two feelings with
this i love
it seems like we're going to be in a
hectic off season right i really do i
don't know how this is going to work i
think you're going to have certain
big-time players
you know sit here early on in free
agency and expect to get some sort of
big offer and it's not going to be to
their liking and they're going to kind
of wait it out and what's going to
happen as we go there so i love that
part of it i mean it gives us to talk
about it's going to make these teams
work and have to be creative and we're
going to see a lot of changeover that's
really cool
but also like
i don't know mike and again tell me you
know we just spent a segment talking
about whoa jerry jones knows what's in
the future yeah it's a lot of damn money
and cash right between the gambling and
the new tv deals and all of that to
where
there's a part of me that wants to be
like
you know
can't the owners take on this burden why
do the players gotta make less money i
mean they're still playing football
you know again they're billionaires and
they're gonna make more money as we know
and they know what's coming down the
road so i guess there's a part of me too
that gets a little bit pissed off sorry
liverpool and getting like where i just
go
why are the you know why the player is
going to have to get crushed through
this and and then that bothers me so go
ahead correct me or give me your stuff
here
two things to remember yeah one last
year the players got 100 cents on the
dollar yeah everything they were
supposed to earn nothing was put into
escrow other sports leagues they put
money into escrow let's wait and see how
are we going to deal with the losses
none of the pandemic losses were
absorbed by the players in the year of
the pandemic that was the negotiation
that was done last year to get the doors
open to get the season on track right
but
okay all right i'll just say other
sports didn't play full seasons either
though the nfl right no they played a
full season they got 100 cents on the
dollar right but there were still losses
the the owners did not get 100 cents on
the dollar last year because most of
them had empty stadiums or mostly empty
stadiums so the owners took a loss the
game took a loss if they didn't do the
deal last year to spread the losses over
three years the salary cap this year i
was told last week would be in the range
of 160. could you imagine a drop from
198 to
what they thought was going to be
208 minimum down to 160 that's what they
were looking at so they've spread it out
over multiple years and yes the money
will be there this is where the the bs
that's been thrown out there to prop up
the cowboys getting a raw deal because
they allowed themselves to
misjudge the room with dak prescott
falls apart because for now we know that
there's going to be money in the future
for now there isn't for now they're
recovering and when you have a business
model chris that's premised on sharing
the money that comes through the cash
register
in the unlikely event that there's a
year
where less money than you thought came
through the cash register that's going
to hurt the employees and yeah it's less
more money's coming but for now it's not
there and for now the cap goes down and
it could have been worse and it's going
to take a few years to recover from it
so that's why we are where we are teams
would
i'd say a lot of the teams would have
rather had a much higher salary cap
they've got the money to deal with it
they've got the cash and they know right
the future is going to be a lot brighter
yeah but you got a lot of other teams
saying hey this is the deal this is the
deal this is the life we've chosen we
split the pie and last year the pie
wasn't very big that's the pie we split
doesn't matter how big the pie is going
to get in the future yeah okay you know
i know because i know yeah you know i
feel like we've we've i've heard those
rumors too that certain teams are just
like man i wish it was you know close to
what it was last year whatever we could
have handled it you know we're not in
that problem now you know i don't know
you're right we don't we don't ever hear
about the teams that you know go oh we
have major cash issues or things like
that and we i don't know who there's
another category right there's a
category of teams that planned for this
right and saw what was coming and would
otherwise have the cash but they see a
competitive advantage in having the cap
low
if it was 198 we'd be fine but it's one
it's
182.5 we'll be better because we saw
this we anticipated this we planned for
it and there's a way for the patriots to
be in better position relative to their
competitors that's part of this too
that's the third counter you get the
haves you've got the have lesses and
then you've got the haves who are happy
to have less for a year because it helps
them in their short-term objectives to
establish a winning program let me ask
you this like how do you envision the
start of free agency this year right
usually we have those first two or three
days
that first week is the big money week
right where it's just every day we got
three or four big contracts and marquee
players and it's awesome like do you
think it's going to be the same this
year i mean just to me yes you do huh
stars are still going to get paid the
stars are still going to get paid but
it's a second time you guys get
franchise tagged it's the mid-level guys
that are going to get screwed you're
going to have and and see what's going
to happen is
there's going to be more guys who think
there are stars than there are stars
that's again there's going to be guys
with expectations and their agents are
pumping up their heads about oh boy how
about this oh you're gonna get you and
then you find out it's not there now the
agents need to do a very good job during
this tampering time illegal for now
legal next week to know what their guys
are worth so they can set their
expectations so they're not stunned when
the numbers aren't there you know hey
i've been talking to some of these teams
it's just not there you got to be ready
for this it's not going to be i don't
see it coming you got to tell them now
so they're not floored next week when
they don't get their big offers but i
think the true star players are going to
get
a significant offer or 10 franchise tags
would have been used this year yeah you
don't use those franchise tags if you
think the guys are going to walk out the
door to some gigantic offer or if
they're not going to walk out the door
to some gigantic offer somewhere else
there's no reason to use the franchise
tag if you don't fear that so i think
the stars will get paid and there always
is going to be a team that makes a
business decision not a football
decision to to go out and grab that guy
on the first day of free agency to sell
tickets and sell jerseys and all that
stuff so
uh that that's that's how i think you're
gonna go this place
guys in the middle are gonna get screwed
that's what's gonna happen and they need
to be ready for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports